so let me give you an example i'm going
to word this to you and then i'll write
down the symbols
can you prove that the average
of two square numbers and i'm the sim by
the way turning this into symbols is
part of the question which is why i'm
deliberately not
writing that for you the average of two
square numbers
is always going to be bigger than make
sure i get my inequality direction right
it's always going to be bigger than the
square
of the average of the two numbers you
started with does that make sense let me
say it one more time right
you have two numbers two numbers if you
squared them both and then averaged
whatever you got
right you started with two numbers you
squared them and then you took the
average of whatever the sum was
okay that's always going to be bigger
than if you
took those two numbers you started with
find the average first
and then square okay can you turn that
into symbols
can you think about whether one or
several of these strategies
might help you to actually prove that
i'll give you about a minute to see if
you can at least state it
and then i'll put it up on the board i'm
still not going to show you the answer
but at least you'll know
you're on the right track have a shot
turn that into some symbols
so i'm sensing that feeling in your
brain
when you're like uh where am i going
or i think i have something but is it
right let me help you out first by
telling you
how not to do this question because it's
so important
as you've seen in this topic counter
example
can be very powerful so eyes up i
promise everything i'm about to write i
will leave on the board so you'll have
the time
to jot it down afterwards but i really
want your focus for this part because
it's a crucial bit right at the
beginning
that several of you because i've had a
look at your books i know you've missed
so
still waiting for full attention
we're almost there
thank you all right let's have a go now
i promised i would show you how not to
do this before i show you how to do it
here's how not to do this
this is my algebra i've worked so hard
to turn this
verbal mess into a symbolic nice thing
now i'm going to start doing things with
this i'm going to be like oh
i know i want to try and do what i can
see
here right see that getting everything
on one side
this is what i want to work with and
then i start to say well on the right
hand side i've got that being greater
than 0
because i subtracted it and then off i
go and continue right
what's the problem with this line of
argument why is this an issue
in our topic nature of proof before i
even go any further i've already made a
huge
blunder anyone want to tell me
it's solving what do you mean by or what
does anyone think that means like i'm
i am kind of trying to solve get down to
the bottom here
why is that a problem i love solving
things what's the big
deal again you've taken the statement as
true
which is what you're already trying to
believe
right in lesson one in this topic right
we said statements
are the things you're going to be
working with right mathematical
statements
either true or they are false sometimes
you don't know which it is sometimes
it's conditional
but the point of a proof question is i
want to
establish the fact that this is true
that's my job right
but everything i've i'm going to
continue from here is actually standing
on the foundation
of this already being true otherwise you
can't do anything with it does that make
sense
so if you have a look and this is why i
keep using these same letters over and
over again this stands for
required to prove i can write this thing
down i want it in my head
but i don't want to write it down as if
i know it to be the case because then
you've already started
at your logical conclusion and wherever
you go at the end you'll be like oh
what have i just established answer
nothing because that's where you started
okay
so here's how i'm going to do this
instead i can't say this because i'm not
using
this required to prove line as a
foundation there's lots of ways to do
this first bit but i think a way that's
fairly nice and neat is just to say well
this thing
having subtracted this from both sides
this is the thing that i want you can
see if i prove this
then it implies this which is what i'm
after
so all i have to do is say well how do i
introduce this thing
i'm going to consider this particular
mathematical object where did i get it
from
and the answer is this is the thing that
was on the left of the inequality
and then this is the thing that was on
the right of the inequality
that's the object i'm now thinking about
and now i can let loose on my
all the algebraic manipulation that i
want and i can try and prove
that this thing is greater than zero
which will prove that the original
inequality
is what i'm after does that make sense
now from here actually several of you
have some pretty
good working you can see for instance
this equals
like you're going to get this is going
to be 2 but that's going to become a
4 when you square it out so i'm going to
anticipate i want to collect like terms
i'll write this with a denominator of
four
and then i'll get busy expanding this
thing so what do you get on the
numerator
this is the easy bit yeah this is a
squared square
sure you can do it whichever order you
like that's okay addition's commutative
after all okay so i've got this
right uh and you can see you've got a
whole bunch of like terms because i've
already got my common denominators so
how many
a squareds well i have left on the top
y squared and one b squared single a
squared a
single b squared and then what else do i
get on the numerator
yeah what's your negative right so minus
two a b but
hopefully at this point you're like aha
this is another object having simplified
that i can work on i should forget i
shouldn't forget that there's division
by four
what can you do with this numerator that
uses one of these techniques over here
what can you do with it
you can starts with an f what's this
thing called i can factorize this right
so this is actually a perfect square
namely this
perfect square right that's going to be
greater
than four i can now say hold on a second
remembering that right at the beginning
of this i said
this big umbrella over this is that
we're in real number land
so this thing here right a
minus b if a is real
and b is real then what can you tell me
about a minus b
also real right so i've got a real
number being squared
the smallest that can possibly be is
zero make sense
so i can say and this is this is that
weird bit going to this whole like we
can
change what's happening to both sides
right i can say that this
is greater than or equal to
0 that's a claim i also need a
substantiation what's my substantiation
a
minus b that's a real number
because a and b are real numbers does
that make sense
now it's true there's one thing that i
left out it's somewhat usually assumed
but
a good nice neat question unlike me a
human being will always state this
explicitly at the beginning
when we say a and b we're also not just
going to include that a and b are real
but we tend to mean when we use
different premium rules we also tend to
mean that a and b
you should write this down because the
phrase you're going to see fair bit and
b
are distinct you might remember this
word back from when we were doing
uh discriminate quadratics sometimes you
got roots that were together
but sometimes they were apart which is
what we mean by this word
so i've so far got that this left hand
side minus right hand side
is greater than or equal to zero
i actually don't want that equal to case
if i return back to my original question
it's just
an inequality without the boundary so
how do i get rid of using this fact that
i've just reminded you of how do i get
rid of that boundary
what do you think bran
yeah very good and be a distinct i can
say that just like i did in this line i
can state that
algebraically i can say but
a is not equal to b
yeah since and b are distinct
and what that applies is a minus b it
can't be
zero like i've just subtracted b from
both sides are you okay
with that flow of logic there this
implies this
so therefore that's gotten rid of my
boundary case so now i can tie this up
in a nice neat bow what have i got i
promised that everything would stay on
the board i think that's just barely
still true if i say
that i began with my left hand side and
right hand side
let's write that down a squared plus b
squared on two average of the squares
and i'm subtracting a plus b
on to the square of the averages what
have i just
established that that's greater than
zero i got that it was greater than or
equal to zero and then i went a step
further
to prove that it's greater than zero
full stop okay and now i'm right here at
this line
see how i've gotten there right so now i
can get back to the thing
that i wanted a squared plus b squared
sum or rather average of the squares
is greater than the square
of the average how do you feel about
that is that okay
do you see how we had to use these
pieces here